members of congress are spending more
money than ever
on their personal security it's a tragic
reflection of the times we live in
gabby giffords was shot meeting with
constituents in arizona
steve scalise was shot practicing for a
charity baseball game
elected officials on both sides of the
aisle have been threatened with all
manner of violence
because of these acts and threats of
violence members of congress are allowed
to spend campaign money
on their safety some members of congress
even travel with personal security when
they're in their districts and states
there's also a police presence when
requested for members of congress
the capitol itself is heavily guarded
police are
everywhere there are metal detectors and
dogs trained to detect guns and
explosives and panic buttons and
restricted access
you name it and it's there safety is
priority number one
for members of congress as it should be
but what about you are you safe
do you feel safe could your neighborhood
benefit from greater police presence
is your place of work armed with metal
detectors and guard dogs or the
streets you walk and ride down line with
police
cars do you have personal security when
you travel
i understand full well why members of
congress spend money on their personal
safety
i just don't understand why some members
of congress don't feel the same way
about your safety if their safety is the
highest priority
shouldn't your safety be too
cory bush represents st louis missouri
in congress
she wants to defund the police
well let me be more precise she wants to
defund
your police but not her police
she spent nearly seventy thousand
dollars on her own personal security
last year i don't know about your city
or state but
seventy thousand dollars would get you
your own personal police officer
in south carolina 24 hours a day
seven days a week corey bush tells us
she is progressive the better word
might be hypocritical she wants to
defund
your police while she has a robust
personal security detail
in washington and st louis and that
sends the clear message that her safety
is more important than yours and
speaking of saint louis do you
know what would happen if you were
supposed to be in court
and did not show up i'll tell you what
would happen
you would be in jail for contempt of
court prosecutors in saint louis failed
to
show up for court and murder cases were
dismissed
not shoplifting cases not drug cases
murder cases and these murder cases were
not
dismissed because of a lack of evidence
and they were not dismissed because they
arrested the wrong person for the wrong
crime
the prosecutor did not
show up for court on multiple
occasions the prosecutor's office in
saint louis
is also run by yet another progressive
named kimberly gardner
and that office is a living breathing
train wreck felony cases are being
dismissed in
record numbers prosecutors aren't
showing up for court
cases are being assigned to prosecutors
who are out on maternity leave
and because that office is a disaster
prosecutors are quitting that office in
staggering numbers
when kimberly gardner ran to be the top
prosecutor for st
louis we knew she would be soft on crime
and hard on the police
that's what progressive prosecutors are
when you go to kimberly gardner's
campaign website it's the normal
platitudes you expect from these
so-called progressive prosecutors
less prison more social workers soft on
crime
but hard on cops and then lots of
psychobabble about
reimagining crime but i did see one
thing that stuck out
she said she would quote attack and
prevent
violent crime attack and prevent she
said
how about you show up for court and not
let murder cases get dismissed
what if we just start there
crime is the toughest tax of all on the
poor
you look at the neighborhoods where the
violent crime is taking place and it's
not country clubs and gated communities
it is neighborhoods that cannot afford
to pay seventy thousand dollars
for their own personal protection it's
communities where you actually have to
show up for court when your case is
called
if you truly care about the poor then
help keep them
alive and keep their homes from being
burglarized and their property from
being stolen
funding your own police force while you
advocate to cut the police for others is
not progressive
it's hypocritical allowing murder cases
to be dismissed because you can't even
show up for court
is not progressive it's incompetent
if you really want to defund the police
start with your own
and if you really want to attack and
prevent violent crime
show up for court otherwise crime
remains just
another tax on the poor a tax they often
pay with their lives
and that doesn't sound very progressive
to me hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else